>> Laura: IT’S FRIDAY WHICH
MEANS IT IS TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLLIES, IMPEACHMENT ADDITION WE
ARE JOINING US WITH ALL THE
DETAILS, RAYMOND ARROYO,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
YOU SAW A MOMENT AT THE TRIAL
LAST NIGHT THAT TOLD A BIGGER
STORY.
>> DID, JERRY NADLER MOVED AS
FAST AS HE HAS EVER MOVED TO
ANSWER, EVEN WHEN LEAD MANAGER
ADAM SCHIFF TRIED TO STOP HIM.
>> ANY OTHER COMMENTS THE SENATE
WOULD BENEFIT FROM HEARING
BEFORE WE ADJOURNED FOR THE
EVENING?
>> MR. CHIEF JUSTICE, MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE.
>> JERRY, JERRY, JERRY.
IT REMINDED ME OF ANOTHER TEAM
THAT ALSO KIND OF FELL APART AND
HAD A BIG FALLING OUT.
>> NO, LISTEN TO ME.
NOW!
I JUST WANT TO KNOW, WAS THAT
HARD?
>> Laura: RAYMOND, RAYMOND,
RAYMOND.
>> BOTH OF THESE JERRIES HAD
ENOUGH OF THAT SCHIFF.
NANCY PELOSI IS REALLY THE ONE
TO BLAME FOR THE ANIMIST ANIMOSI
SHE PUT HER FRIEND AND HER
ACCOMPLISHED SCHIFF.
>> Laura: HE WANTED IT TO BE
SCHIFF’S LIST.
>> AND HE MADE THE HORRIBLE
COMMENTS TO THE SENATOR SAYING
THIS IS A TRAITOROUS VOTE.
THAT SET OFF ALARMS AND THEN
THESE BEFORE HUSTLE MAY HAVE
BEEN PAYBACK FOR THIS MOMENT
LAST WEEK.
>> MISTRESS BEFORE, REPUBLICANS
HAVE BEEN GOING, I’M GOING TO
RESPOND TO THE QUESTIONS.
>> I’M GOING TO RESPOND TO THE
QUESTIONS AND NADLER HAD TO SIT
BACK AND TAKE IT.
IT DIDN’T MATTER WHETHER SCHIFF
OR NADLER TOOK THIS THING, WHO
WAS DRIVING THE BUS, THERE
WASN’T ENOUGH GAS TO GET HIM
WHERE THEY WANTED IT TO GO.
IT’S OVER BUT IT SHOWS THE
TENSION AND ANIMOSITY.
>> Laura: THERE SOMETHING
ABOUT ADAM SCHIFF WHEN HE GETS A
LITTLE BIT EXERCISED ABOUT
SOMETHING.
HIS EYES, HE DOES THE MARTY
FELDMAN EYES THING.
>> WE’VE GOT TO MOVE ON, LAURA.
>> Laura: SINCE IMPEACHMENT
BEGAN, THE MEDIA HAS TAKEN THE
DEMOCRAT LINE AND THEY’RE TRYING
TO CHARACTERIZE THE PROCEEDINGS
THIS WAY.
>> ANY OTHER COMMENTS THE SENATE
WOULD BENEFIT FROM HEARING
BEFORE WE ADJOURNED FOR THE
EVENING?
>> JERRY, JERRY, JERRY.
>> MR. CHIEF JUSTICE.
>> THAT WAS THE WRONG BITE.
THEY WERE ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT
THIS BEING A SOLEMN, SERIOUS
DICTATION.
I’M NOT SURE SENATOR
KAMALA HARRIS GOT THE MEMO.
WATCH CHUCK SCHUMER’S REACTION
WHEN SHE WAS A LITTLE LESS THAN
SOLEMN AND SERIOUS AND SERIOUS.
>> DO YOU VIEW IT AS AT LEAST A
PARTIAL VICTORY THAT YOU HAVE A
REPUBLICAN -- I WILL START
AGAIN.
DO YOU VIEW IT AS AT LEAST A
PARTIAL VICTORY --
>> START AGAIN, SOLEMN.
>> Laura: LET’S CUT THAT OUT.
I’M SURPRISED KAMALA DIDN’T
BREAK INTO THAT I REMEMBER THAT
LITTLE DANCE?
>> FRANKLY, IT MADE ME PRETTY
SAD WHEN I WATCHED THIS.
BARRY BLACK OPENED THE SENATE
TRIAL WITH THIS PRAYER.
LISTEN CLOSELY.
>> REMIND OUR SENATORS THAT THEY
ALONE ARE ACCOUNTABLE TO YOU FOR
THEIR CONDUCT.
LORD HELP THEM TO REMEMBER THAT
THEY CAN’T IGNORE YOU AND GET
AWAY WITH IT, FOR WE ALWAYS REAP
WHAT WE SOW.
>> IF YOU’RE GOING TO CONDEMN
PEOPLE AND RAISE THE JUDGMENT OF
GOD TO THEM, DON’T DO IT OVER A
PARTISAN THING LIKE THIS
IMPEACHMENT BEER THIS IS
DIVISIVE.
HE SHOULD BE BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER.
I’M SORRY, I THINK THE CHAPLAIN
WENT ABOVE AND BEYOND --
>> Laura: THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF PRAYERS.
YOU FELT LIKE IT WAS --
>> HE SAID EARLIER IN THE WEEK
THE TRIAL WILL MAKE THE NATION
STRONGER, WISER, AND BETTER.
HOW?
RAISE YOUR MORAL VOICE FOR
THINGS THAT MATTER.
ABORTION, RELIGIOUS LIBERTY.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, BEFORE WE
GO THEY SAY A PICTURE IS WORTH A
THOUSAND WORDS.
>> YES, THEY DO.
>> Laura: BUT IS IT REALLY THE
CASE?
DO WE SEE THE FACES OF WHAT IT
ALL LOOKS LIKE AT THE END?
♪ ♪
>> OH, SO SAD.
THIS IS AFTER THE SENATE VOTED
NO WITNESSES.
VERY DEJECTED.
>> Laura: IMAGINE HAVING TO
DRINK WITH HER TONIGHT.
>> WON’T YOU HELP THIS ANCHOR?
>> Laura: THIS IS LIKE A SAVE
THE CHILDREN AD.
>> YOU KNOW THE FACTORY LINE,
THE WORLD IS A LOOKING GLASS AND
GETS BACK TO EVERY MAN WHAT HIS
FACE SHOWS?